we're gonna send you 300 bucks to do
something fun with the kiddos
yeah man it's not much but it's
something just a just a little just a
little uh
welcome back to regular life fun that's
what's up i appreciate i'm about to call
the weed guy i told him
get your life together touch me bro
i'm not touching you dude
say something i'm giving up on you
damn story of my life man
oh a lot of conversations i never had
with people i'm proud to be
an american at least i know i'm free
that's all i know of this song it's a
good song man you know at one time it
was one of the top
50 songs in america oh yeah yeah how did
it chart can you see how that song
charted
nick it's an older song right i think so
someone try something no one's writing
new songs about america are they
greenwood that's what it is lee
greenwood made that hitter
and when did it really when did it chart
how high did it get what do you think it
made
top 20 for sure how could you not it's
as american as it gets
i think it was like around the same time
as like that um and i will always love
you by whitney houston
oh that old
that was position seven number 16 on
billboards
that was 1984. god
how can they why don't we remix that
[ __ ]
it said it chartered to number one after
36 years hell yeah because of trump
america
really yeah america wow um
anyway well here we are we're back at it
doug
dude i'm trying to think of what's going
on oh i uh
uh uh somebody sent me a faberge egg man
you ever had one of those bring it up
nick
is that what uh that's the colorful eggs
right
the fancy eggs yeah you're worth a lot
of money you try and eat it did you
somebody sent me a fat burgers egg man
look at it
these [ __ ] are nice dude no you know
i got to get some pictures of it it's
nice is it not it's like those
what do you do what the [ __ ] you do with
that i guess you put in your house
centerpiece for the new crib
look at that bird one yeah something
like that make an omelette baby look at
that bastard
yeah i'd rather see a cabbage i get your
crib really
yeah for me put a straw in you ever put
a straw on a cadbury egg
no that's a great idea i could easily
see you doing that no i just use my
tongue like an anteater
dude will you have cadbury eggs in your
crib when i go over yeah i will thanks
man i'll get some
you want me to hide them or just leave
them out just leave them out don't make
me work for it oh
you're getting lazy bruh you should put
one of those on your wife bro that's how
you do it dude you hide one of those in
the old lady you know and get that
pantied around
yeah do ant eaters have long tongue or
whatever oh
yeah do you ever see an anteater tongue
and they and
what they do is they stick that whole
tongue down that ant house
and just load up the tongue full of
black ants how do they get it in the
little ant holes
does that look they're designed to go
down them holes
look at that thing okay manny okay
nothing how fun that must be okay dora
look at that thing can you get a video
of that thing we doing a little bit of
work nick or what
oh yeah bring that [ __ ] up it's bringing
up still images like it's 1999.
yeah it takes you drawing and anthony
yes
yeah they're designed to eat demands man
that's
wow those big mounds these giant mounds
are the work of millions of termites
i'm these tireless men the far more lush
i like how they're trying to make it all
suspenseful yeah where do you eat
it's an ooh look at that juicy nose oh
dude they almost look like a reindeer
huh aren't they cool
oh they naughty they hit them
someone said they can smell cancer too
if it's in you
i bet they go get cancer bro dude that's
the thing that everybody keeps messing
with these dogs saying hey smell who's
got cancer
get an anteater at the airport dog dude
yeah nothing licked my butt
okay go ahead manny yeah get you some oh
dora dude get nose deep in that ass
yeah look at that daddy percocet baby
you got to be on some percocet so that
kind of works molly percocet
dude that's really yeah mask on man i'm
all for anteaters that's that cocaine
dude let's get a baby auntie there's the
mascot in here
i don't know can you see how much they
are nick
take it out of my pay and buy an
anteater okay
well let me see how much they are yeah
okay
are the are they legal nick ranging
costs from 3 500 to 8
000. oh dude take it on my pay and buy
one oh i don't want the white one
really no i want the more chocolate one
um
anteater behavior what does it say they
visit many nests each day
oh they're blind basically they got anal
oh in threatener attack anteater will
back up against the tree or grab onto
branch with their tail
and defend themselves with their claws
they also have another line of defense
liquid that is four times more potent
than a skunk scent hell yeah it comes
out of their buttocks it's gonna smell
like [ __ ] in here
wow i don't know if it's a poop smell
you think
oh i bet it's horrid worse than a skunk
i don't want any
you don't you okay i do not want any of
that yeah i don't think we get it man
hold on it says uh is it if it's
prolonged temperature above 90 it does
get hot in here
if it's kept too cold at 65 or below
your anteater can become
sick oh we don't want to ant you with a
runny nose oh
can you imagine how much running would
come out of it
they got big ol and then nick and chin
you guys trade off whose house is going
to stay at during the weekends like
like a kid dude i got to tell you this
you got to watch the movie the tv show
serpent
serpent it's on netflix yeah what's it
about bro
it's good and it looks horrible from the
way they advertise it kind of it just
looks bad
that's it right there i literally cannot
wait to leave here and go watch it
that's how good oh it's about serial
killers bro it's
goo really yes is there subtitles
is it a foreign film no it's a mirror
it's like a little bit of both but only
a little bit of subtitles
but it's so good man you still haven't
told me what it's about it's good
i know you keep saying about killers bro
oh i'm in you can't handle you think you
could fight a killer
yeah beat the [ __ ] out of like jeffrey
dahmer what if when you were a kid you
think a
a child predator would have got you oh
yeah easy with cafe eggs a van
i've always liked vans oh that'd be an
easy snatch
easy snack for them boys damn don't you
think you'd be pretty easy to get in the
truck back in the day
i think i woulda i think i would i
wonder who would have been more likely
to get kidnapped did we already do this
i don't think so nick you were never
kidnapped i don't think so
i was adopted that's kind of the same
thing oh yeah you don't know your real
parents
like kidnapped by the devil he does he
knows his mom right or what tell
sorry nick no it's all good uh no my mom
no real
uh or any desire to have interaction
with my dad but uh know my mom
a little bit little sends a little bit
of hate in your voice when you talk
about your dad
nick chen brendan he's pretty he's
perceptive
he's perceptive yeah brendan
well no you can't blame the guy the guy
just dipped out on you and then
probably not you're this famous producer
he wants to be back in your life what if
he was like in a car accident or
something he wasn't
he wasn't oh he wasn't he's just a
deadbeat am i right nick
damn you know he lives in wisconsin
i believe so i believe i think he lives
in my hometown no way he's just like a
drip street
street walker no way oh wow he just
strolls the streets
you think he's ever done any crime uh
definitely
hell yeah nick nice sounds kind of cool
you know what you don't want to reach
out there and give him the culture
recording
uh baby maybe that'd be crazy if he came
in here that's how dedicated
nick is of the show yeah it is a
stranger
i do see that chin can't even get any
any of his family members in here you
guys want them in there
huh you guys want my phone yeah get some
of those snail hunters in here dude look
at
this
snail do you have any family members
that are like super charismatic that
like could just blow us away
as much as me it's charismatic and
his aunt is hot yeah if my aunt came in
she's loud and crazy you would love her
yeah sounds like a great time yeah isn't
she in texas yeah
she's in texas what part um
they just recently moved near the coast
area i'd love to houston's near the
coast
oh you might be right near there i'll
let her know
don't come to the show i'll keep her out
yeah
dude um i'll tell you this let's talk oh
oh today well we also have oh but
serpent you got to see it man i don't
work for serpent this isn't an ad
but man if you like crime you like
secrecy yeah i like all that and also
the way it's shot brendan this is what
you don't understand about a lot of
television the way it's
shot style very good
i'm in dude i told you i was in from the
jump you keep selling it
yeah well it's gonna be a read on king
of the sting now if you care you'd watch
it on your phone right now
okay i got into 60 days in man did you
this guy's a convicted felon
oh he is i think so sorry brother i
shouldn't have said that i didn't know
you were on yet because with that
backdrop that doesn't scream convicted
felon yeah it does he could be anywhere
right now you think that's a real bridge
behind him
i thought he was on golden gate
i think your volume your volume man you
gotta change the
let's say you have any felons in your
family i think so
nick's dad was a felon i bet you think
nick uh almost guarantee it
wow hey can you put a swipe up to who's
more likely to get
kidnapped as a child me or brendan yeah
christian and then what you probably
should brother
we can almost hear you we just can't
hear you yet so it's okay we're just
gonna um
it's on his end christian price probably
get a picture of me and through as kids
though
i was a cute ass kid probably get a
picture of me and theo as kids and see
who's more likely to be kidnapped
do you guys have like oh yeah do i on
instagram somewhere i'll send you some
is it on his end nick
you guys got me now there we go yeah
all right what's up brandon what's up
theo what's up brother
what's going on man where where where
what what up
you know out here we're living
dangerously so the reason i became a
felon without
as part of a cannabis grow with three
other homies
up in marin and one day one of them got
pissed off at another and tried to
[ __ ] kill him with the baseball bat
while he was sleeping metal baseball bat
somehow he was able to escape out the
room burst into my room i was able to
tackle her take the baseball bat she ran
away
the other roommate ended up trying to
drive him to the er
but she was [ __ ] waiting for him and
she rammed his little honda fit
off the road with her big ass van she
called the biohazard battle cruiser
and so they had to roll back me and my
now ex so we had to rush him to the er
and
we were waiting in the waiting room at
the er and sure enough a couple cops
pull up
i gave him the little lowdown and
on her way home with my busted ass
friend with
60 stitches in his head we arrive and
greeted with the drug task force
there and uh just because the marijuana
stuff
yeah yeah this is back in the day then
daddy it was 10 years ago
it's not that long ago brandon it's only
a decade it's a long time because we
decided 800 plants indoors was too much
so
you know we got busted uh they tried to
hit me with four felonies i took a plea
deal
amen and they gave me one felony but
they chose the worst one they chose
using a place of residence to
store and process narcotics so it's
sounding like i was cooking meth
oh yeah yeah and yeah that [ __ ] so how
long did you do in the slammer
that's also alright before we go on
that's also i think a good way to
describe
shonies as well whatever you just
described
i had to do tw i part of the deal was i
was able to do 29 eight hour
work days with the park rangers it
wasn't that bad but it still sucked
because that was a lot of time
yeah when you got a felony on your
record it's tough to live that down
brendan you don't know that i don't but
i've heard i watched last season i'm
sorry brother
um what so what was the toughest part
about living in a place where people
didn't even have were you guys
what are you what were you guys doing in
there you guys were but you you never
did any uh real jail time right you were
you were helping out the [ __ ]
no jail time just uh work days
300 hours community service uh
you know i lost my job couldn't get an
apartment and
all this told you [ __ ] that comes
with it you know
do you feel like the punishment fit the
crime
i do not uh because especially that girl
that tried to kill my roommate got those
charges dropped so oh wow
i was like man and how did she get them
dropped what was she what did she say
she had been kidnapped or something
no i don't know they were just like well
you're already doing time for attempted
murder so we'll just drop this one
oh so she did some hardcore time she's
still doing like 12 years
she's in there maybe she's out right now
i hope not i don't know you know they're
releasing
criminals yeah yeah dude totally they'll
let anybody out to rob a foot locker
dude yep
um now what about this so she hit him
with that baseball bat and then while he
was asleep
yep oh at like four in the morning
imagine waking up to that [ __ ] a metal
baseball batman
was she after seven bro do not hit me
around
was she hot not hot not into men so
do you think any of the the crime was
motivated
by her the fact that she hated men
overall
maybe yeah i wouldn't put it i would i
wouldn't hate crimes
still wondering why there's a lot of
hate crimes going on there sometimes
people are paint people black and go
leave them outside somewhere so people
will hit them
[ __ ] see it all the time i i haven't
seen it that much no not that much
but um so what else so now that you're a
felon what else is going on
uh you know just trying to get by
focusing on work
trying to get ahead uh trying to get
around these obstacles
gonna try to get this felony expunge
since it's all legal now
so can you can you never get it off your
record or is it what's your fault
i got an attorney and she said she could
be able to
wipe it off so then i hopefully i could
start
living life now after all this what a
tough
gig dude and are you still uh selling
wheat or
drugs no not anymore it's not worth it
after legalization prices dropped and i
just threw in the towel got a real job
do you go ahead brendan what do you do
now i'm a construction inspector
oh yeah okay i like that pretty chill
yeah do you miss the [ __ ] game do you
miss being caught up
the hustle i missed because after that i
started growing
outdoors up in the mountains and i do
miss waking up early
spoken to join watering the plants
hanging out
living life slow but it's just the
inconsistency on the pay days is what
really this makes it hard do you have to
shake some people down that didn't pay
you
no i know unfortunately not i never had
to do that but we had
when i lived in the mountains we had
some neighbors they were a winery and
the winery workers had a history of
coming down to that property and jacking
everyone
so i just had to walk around like a good
gun being like yeah don't [ __ ] with me
you didn't end up robbing me that year
so it worked out wow
so there's a lot of beef there's a lot
of beef out there between there was
there was a lot of beef between wine and
weed workers out there
well if the wine workers see rapes and
vapes baby these people go ahead
yeah they'll come down they'll take
they'll take some home you know and who
is it honestly was it mexicans
yeah yes yeah yeah i'm mexican too i
mean it's just
i'm mexican to the lions for that year i
was there
right right right so you got a really so
there's a lot of turf wars going on out
there
oh it gets crazy up in the mountains man
you never know what to expect you should
have sent that you should have sent that
lesbian with a bad attitude to patrol
the [ __ ] plants dog
yeah rainbow fight you should have sent
that broad over to freaking hustle up a
little bit
dude send big gene up there hit some
[ __ ] with the face with the bat
well look man i'm going to say this we
want to we're going to throw
we want to send you 500 bucks to help
out with the felony to pay your attorney
man so that'll just a little
just a little something just to help you
out and keep you motivated man
it's tough to bounce back from felonies
and uh
that's it man that's all i can think of
right now i don't know what else to say
thank you guys so much holy [ __ ]
does the 500 helps out oh yeah yeah
definitely helps get the ball rolling
uh i have an attorney picked out so
oh [ __ ] let's do it yeah going and
finished
yeah get that [ __ ] put behind you bro
you know what i'm saying we got to fight
back against angry lesbians and angry
straights yeah you can't let them win
man
yep nope peace to love man that's what
we got to strive
for amen dude well look man keep growing
a bright future for yourself bro
and uh and if you do get back in the
game get into some [ __ ] coke or
something something i can do yeah and
don't fall asleep around any lesbians i
learn from it my man
i know huh keep an eye out yeah
all right brother good luck man yeah
we'll send you that money if that helps
i'll definitely help you out man
awesome man thank you guys so much yeah
you bet eric thanks for checking out the
show gang gang baby yeah buzz buzz
man one of my biggest problems brendan
is
guess what it is i would probably say
shipping packages man it's exhausting
how did you know that because i have the
same
freaking problem do you my problem is
also doing all the tape and everything
and
they don't even know where to go someone
get the brock's put together i'm so
exhausted
i don't know what to what to do well
thank god for ship station
ship station's number one shipping
software for e-commerce sellers
with more than five-star reviews than
anyone all right import orders from any
sales channel
ship with any carrier using the deeply
discounted rates oh that's nice automate
just about any shipping tasks
spend a lot less time theo on shipping
and a lot more time growing your
business
no matter what you're selling amazon
etsy your own merch shipstation funnels
all your orders
into one simple interface that you can
manage from anywhere even though cell
phone
you'll even get access to amazing
discounts with major carriers
including ups fedex and usps
wow dude easily compare carriers choose
the best solution every time
with ship stations small business can
now access the same rates
that are usually reserved for large
fancy
fortune 500 companies ship more in less
time
use our offer code kats to get a 60-day
free trial the thing is if you're
shipping stuff already
see if you can save money man that's a
thing and get it there
betterize your business man that's
shipstation.com
enter offer code kats make ship happen
just go to shipstation.com click on the
microphone at the top of the page
type in kats that's shipstation.com
enter the offer code kats
make ship happen oh man
you know good and well i need help baby
you need help daddy and i got something
for you
listen is there something interfering
with your happiness yes
is it preventing you from achieving your
goals yes
is it ruining this podcast yes yes
better help will assess your needs and
pass you
with your own licensed professional
therapist you can start communicating
under 48 hours it's not a crisis line
it's not self-help
it's professional counseling done
securely online quit talking to your
friends man get a real
profession now brenda's an idiot man
yeah maybe
but pretty mentally stable you can log
into your account anytime and send a
message to your counselor
all right better help is committed to
facilitating great therapeutic matches
catch
what's up daddy making it easy and free
to change counts if you need it
it's more affordable than traditional on
offline counseling
and financial aid is available so better
help once you start living a happier
life today
get off the drugs and get off the bs man
yeah lying to yourself quit lying to
your daddy man if your daddy's alive
this podcast is sponsored by better
helping king and the sting listeners
get 10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com
k-a-t-s quit lying to your podcast host
in fact so many people have been using
better help they are recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
and people are getting better yeah i
think i saw someone the other day i was
like damn y'all better like yep
wow man this podcast king this thing is
sponsored by betterhelp
and you guys get listener you guys get
10 percent off your first month
betterhelp.com kats i said it
uh lauren is not a felon we are waiting
on one who just joined actually but uh
she has a relationship advice
i'd rather talk to lauren than felons
what's up girl
sorry we're busy talking to harry phelan
so this is a refreshing
call yeah good yeah i'm not not a felon
here
just a mom what's up lauren oh what
happened to y'all's dad
nothing my dad no i have a relationship
advice for our
question for you guys um i just had a
baby a year ago right when the pandemic
started
and uh my husband he's ready for baby
number two
and i could use another year or two i
think we have another one so
i wanted to get y'alls input on it yeah
you don't want to get carpal tunnel in
your vagina you know what i'm saying i
think you got to back off a year and
give that thing a little bit of rehab
time you know
nah here's the thing you're in it so you
know it's like you know it's like navy
seals bud
camp you're in it so you might as well
just knock another one out so the kids
are close so they can play together to
keep each other entertained
so it's gonna be hell for about two
years but i'm with i'm with the dude i
hate to side with your man but
i would just grind it out knock that
little sucker out
yeah now mike now my girl is the same so
i have a five-year-old and a
one-year-old so she wanted a lot of time
off
and looking back do you wish you'd have
done it tightened up brandon [ __ ] yeah i
want like five kids
isn't it nice though they're like
there's a little bit of an age and the
five-year-old can like help out or
he helps out yeah for sure i just wish
they were a little closer in age you
know because he's gonna be like a senior
when boston's a freshman you know so
that's always weird
if you do it too far apart they really
don't know each other like how old's
your brother theo
my brother how much older is he than you
40 years 50 years he's 40
i don't know how old he is yeah but i
hope he's doing good
so you're so you got a one-year-old then
you want to wait like three years
you think i think like two more years
probably that's the pandemic
having him right when lockdown started
was not fun oh that's a beast
yeah but that's true now enjoy it why
does your man why do you think your man
wants it right
away he wants what why he wants a lot of
kids
he's he's 35 so okay i'm not i turned 30
in a couple weeks so i just
have some time trying to get you to turn
and burn off that little omelet down
there i feel you he probably reel at you
but it's just a grind but
the problem is once the kid gets like
three the grind becomes easier then you
forget how much of a
you know you're in it man so you just
want to knock it out it's gonna be a
beast for those two three years
yeah but then if you'd wait too long you
keep restarting you keep going through
it
and you could do a smoothie too for a
baby or even a child
yep i mean
thanks guys yeah hopefully that helps
and i'm sorry i gave you any advice i
have no kids and also i'm lonely and
also have a lot of different problems
that keep me from
staying in relationships and really
achieving probably
decent sexual intimacy stuff stuff like
that
but you look nice outside yeah you look
great thanks super nice here
good luck with the kiddo sweet thanks
guys love you guys yeah we're gonna go
talk to you guys
now thanks for your call thanks gang see
ya
oh that was what we passed away no sir
you assumed that that's what we call a
milf where i come from
really oh yeah she's pretty hot tim what
do you think when you see a woman like
that a white woman do you feel like they
accept you or they don't
um some are into some aren't to me but
when i see her i'm gonna guess probably
not
uh something about that tattoo that huge
tattoo on the right arm or a lot yeah
right on
yeah right that's reminding you of what
somebody wore or something that happened
so you think the sleeve
uh makes her not into asians for some
reason that's what
it's clicking in my head like if it was
just purely there's little no tattoos
nation for you i think a little too a
little bit of iwo jima flashback
barley motorcycle kind of stuff that ij
four by four trucks okay okay yeah
you're probably right jen
you know it's funny man because i never
ever have felt any attraction from an
asian woman
not once it's rare
it's very rare isn't it yeah that's what
it is
you don't feel it i just never i never
once have i thought oh
have you been around a lot of asian
girls i've been around some not that
but not a ton right me neither right i
feel like for around them or they dig us
yeah you might be yeah asians love white
guys they do they do well you gotta tell
them to love harder all right
yeah you gotta tell them to be a little
more obvious because i'm not picking up
the
[ __ ] signs yeah put it on your story
dude yeah man
this is kalin uh we can't hear you
kaelin if you can change your audio to
and kaelin did felony yeah caitlin's a
felon
oh wow yeah huh
do some time in my heart huh
can do some time in my mind when i get
home what sorry
she's wearing some uh theo merch oh yeah
be good to yourself hoodie right there
can you hear us caitlyn
i don't think she can but all these
felons have problems with the sound
huh ours is correct must be a felon
thing yeah well apparently they couldn't
hear their parents telling them
tighten up when they were young either
and there's meat hulk or whatever that
kid's name is what's up doug
i thought you'd come tell some know he
always does that look on his face like
he just heard something yeah
can you hear us caitlyn what's up girl
i don't think she can oh she doesn't she
can see us you get we can't hear you we
can't hear you
oh she can't hear us it's her settings
can you change your settings
she's going to try oh she might be
outside
oh she lives outside maybe some felon
thing where they can't face time and
is an air conditioner plugged in outside
that's an air conditioner
and what area is that garage or outside
outside looks like outside
all right okay there we go hey
what's up girl what's up oh my god i'm
so sorry so i like know nothing about
zoom
that's all right neither during this
whole pandemic i've never had to use it
so i'm like trying to have help people
help me out so
that's why so many people are getting in
trouble nobody really knows how to use
it
yeah like i literally had to have my
teenage son
help me to learn how to use it so oh
well that's nice dan
what um what's going on i see you got
that be good to yourself
hoodie right there i sure do and i like
your nails oh i love you guys
yo vaughn i'm a huge fan of both of you
oh thank you okay lynn and you it's nice
you to throw brendan in there as well
yeah she did i was the side
yeah everybody's got some people yeah
it's either a little more gang or a
little more buzz
what um what's going on amen yeah you're
a felon
um so you're a felon that's freaking
honestly it's kind of
i feel like it's kind of attractive
almost yeah it turned you on right
yeah now what happened did they put you
in handcuffs
um oh yeah so yeah oh yeah
what happened girl i don't i don't have
the
greatest like legal history
i've struggled with addiction like most
of my adult life
so so i was always kind of in and out of
um jails but damn
yeah like i went so i live in washington
and i had taken a trip with
my baby's daddy to idaho and he was
going to
like do a drug deal but um
so he got set up and obviously we had no
idea until
they followed us until we got into idaho
and then literally like
idaho is zero tolerance for drugs so
like when it comes down to it no matter
what you have or what story like
doesn't matter they're just hitting you
with time so
yeah so so just because you were with
him he got busted
oh yeah yeah even though like i stated
like i knew what we were doing but i
never stated
i just knew we had drugs on us but just
for being there
so how much time did you do so i did
three years
yeah let's go three years a hard time in
the idaho
state prison there yeah yeah it was
three years mandatory minimum
and it was day for day like in most
prisons in other states you'll get like
good time work time like time and a half
like
idaho's no joke like day for day what
are some things you honestly that
in a little bit of a way you miss about
it
um oh my gosh uh
so i guess kind of the structure
like something i don't know you don't
really have to think about like what am
i gonna do today like it's all just kind
of your meal times
at the time in prison like i was working
jobs like i had stuff to do
i definitely stayed busy yeah so
it was just kind of that idol time i
guess
and was there any and look you're
obviously an attractive woman or you
look attractive over zoom
and um but
is there like a lot of does it get to
the point where you kind of like find
affection with women because there's no
men around or what happens with that
with the men's
so no so i personally know i never did
it's it's called
gay for the stay that was kind of the
term that makes sense
yeah it's like a ramada yeah but it's a
it's like a really
big thing in women's prisons like
whether or not you're a lesbian
like i would say about 75
of the women there oh that's hot yeah
turn out gay for the stay so i
personally did
not if i mean if i was it may have been
with more time but three years did not
yeah three years you're just gay yeah
three year i mean you can get through
three years
yeah yeah now i watched a lot of 60 days
in did you were you with like a posse
straight through the weight
was i what did you have like a posse
like people that protected you
was is it like the female prisons or no
so it wasn't so i was in kind of like a
minimum security prison
they have like a higher risk presence
but um but i mean everybody kind of
clicks up but there's not really
not like a lot of fights or anything
breaking out it's more just like
drama like women just kind of fight with
their mouths you know what i mean
yeah everybody just talks [ __ ] now
there's a lot of drugs in prison too
like in six days in everybody getting
high
yeah yeah that is a fact was it hard to
stay clean in prison was it tougher to
stay clean in prison than out of prison
you know it really it um
like it didn't it came around but
honestly it was like the facility i was
at you still
you get kind of random drug tested every
now and then it only happened to me
twice
but i don't know like something about
three years clean and being three years
behind bars i just kind of realized like
you know it's not worth it because i i
also had with
three years i had five years hanging
over my head of probation
so damn when it came up to my three
years like there was a chance i might
not be getting out and that was
something that they like take into
consideration like
yeah were you a good inmate did you
[ __ ] up a lot so and how long did after
you got out did you take on a date or a
lover
if you if it's okay to ask that i don't
want to be inappropriate i know you said
you have children and stuff but
i'm just kind of curious like a couple
weeks
yeah let's go huh yeah of course is
there is there a felon dating site like
felons only
yeah um i'm sure there is i really
wasn't so when i got out i honestly i
just started like kind of hitting up
guys
that i knew yeah and it was really risky
because it was like guys that i knew
from the past that there's
kind of a chance they may not mean so
but yeah the guy um he's actually my
husband now we have a daughter
so so that was actually a really good
risk like he was actually
newly clean when i got out so and you
guys oh yeah
we've been good you guys are you guys
are clean together now
yes yes that's awesome congratulations
yeah and coming up
in july i'll have eight years oh damn
you're doing the damn thing let's go our
producer nick could use a year
um yeah we don't have a year between the
two of you
if you want to give a year to anybody uh
nick could definitely use one
if you don't mind me asking what was
your drug of choice back in the day
i'm heroin yeah here alone yeah if i was
gonna do something it'd be that
yeah yeah that's go big or go home oh
yeah that's that big boy
yeah you got to go with the big dogs a
shark you got to put that shark in the
water you feel me
you got to do that in the veins dog um
well thank you so much for uh calling in
today
um no thank you yep we really appreciate
it and
congrats on eight years that's a big
deal your first home and you got a kid
oh and a man now this this is a happy
ending
yeah definitely definitely i just wanted
to do a little gift
i want to give we're just going to give
you guys 500 bucks let's go do something
fun with you and the husband and the
kiddo
and uh it's just on behalf of us and so
just a nice thing it's just like um
i don't know just something we thought
we would just do for this for today
felon's fun oh my god thank you so much
yeah no problem
thanks for calling in thanks for sharing
a little bit of re-entry money there you
go so go get back out in the world and
do something yeah don't spend on heroin
though you know
absolutely not it's not even a thought
anymore yeah i'm just making sure
hey yeah that's a good point he's just
checking no i'm just covering my bases
here
yeah thanks caitlin kelly so much
god this guy looks like a felony
this guy looks like mario and luigi's
other brother okay
this is wally
what's up dude what's up ben
i mean there he is
he's a bad service am i still in this
there yeah you're there playboy was
cracking
hey sorry about that i'm in the back of
this quick trip parking lot bro just
trying to get it in what's up oh i've
made some poor choices too brother i
feel you there dude i've done some
things inside of a wawa
and outside of one shout out wawa too
they're selling jocko willing's new
beverage right now too
oh wow that's a big deal yeah just lost
him yeah we lost him
well that makes sense and that's how it
happens guys it's
uh if eric joins or ben joins again
we'll let him in yeah yeah
we don't do headaches do you want to
give that felon five hundo
the lady the lady for sure the guy with
the pierce knows he heard it stop
he heard it he heard it now we have to
yeah i feel like he's been spent on
drugs goddamn really
i do think it's a weird fund a little
bit but the the two people we gave it to
they seem like they really turned it
around the the
the first guy was crunk he was like man
i need that [ __ ] for the lawyers
yeah i should have that right no the s
news to me yeah sorry
i'm sorry that's news to me
look man i want to tell you this in a
tiny apartment in southern california
sure two college dropouts teamed up to
create a watch company that broke all
the rules
fair prices wow unexpected colors and
clean
original designs wow movement
we're into one of the fastest growing
watch brands shipping over 160 countries
across the globe yeah man they got that
sweet minimal sport dive watch all right
sleek professional looking oh you can go
looking for treasure in their watches
that's the thing
some watches you can't you some they
find you looking for treasure they say
oh what happened when we died
my watch broke but in movement it's
quality stuff you could go underwater
above water
whatever water man movement watches have
the looking quality of four to five
hundred dollar watches
but listen we're gonna cut the middleman
go straight to you
all right yeah cut them with a sword
dude if you want to elevate your look
with style that doesn't break the bank
join the movement get 15
percent off today with free shipping and
free returns
by going to mvmt.com kats
again that's the letter m v m
t dot com slash k-a-t-s
god you know you want to get married or
you want to get scared
dude mother's day is coming up and hit
her with that diamond ring saying
thanks for not letting me die mom bezel
that [ __ ] you feel me praise
god brother god diamond nothing says i
love you
more like giving our fancy gift man
words won't get it done
i want to tell you it's like having a
little piece of jesus on your hand there
are
two parts to blue nile business wedding
jewelry and
everyday fine jewelry yup you know what
i'm talking about diamond jewelry
cocktail rings gemstone necklaces etc
step right up
please please recognize that they got
the authentic
good good okay whether you're ready to
pop the question or just mark a special
occasion
and you don't have to be rich rich
either man we got you covered we're
talking about discount prices high
quality unique jewelry
got mother's day you got freaking
engagement rings father's day halloween
labor day get that dark get that opal
bruh for halloween go hard on your lady
or your man if you're a gay man
give up man yeah give your gay friend a
freaking diamond ring for columbus day
why not yeah huh
14.90 blue nile
dot com that's right make the moment
sparkle with jewelry from bluenow.com
listeners get 50 off 50
off man 50 off you crazy yeah this would
get 50
off 500 this is an exclusive for you
guys only
use the code kats that's code cats plus
every orders insurance ship free
arrives in a little discreet package so
it doesn't give away yeah you don't want
it
inside it won't say hey there's a ring
in here he cares or she cares and won't
say that yeah
you might be like what is this yeah yeah
nobody's going to know
shop stress free and find your forever
piece go to bluenile.com today
yo what's up benny jesus christ that was
close
yeah yeah it was what's going on now
where you at man i heard you were a
felon
bro yeah i'm just being out here in
missouri where it's [ __ ] snowing
right now dude
oh wow it's april that's the night get a
gun bro yesterday and now i'm freezing
get a gun and shoot it down that's what
i'm saying they won't let me
rainbow capital dog oh yeah you can't
even get a gun
no gun can't even get one dude damn so
how long can you not get a gun for
forever the rest of my life yeah forever
i got a marijuana felony so like
hopefully whenever that becomes legal
i get expunged i get a gun i become a
felon again
yes oh keep it rolling yeah you're gonna
rob a bank dude you uh
so what happened with the with the weed
charges what happened man
oh i did i was selling weed when i was
uh
19 years old thinking i was hot [ __ ] you
know in a small
town in missouri and uh dude i was
literally in the middle of selling these
young kids some pot
and they were like 16 years old i was
19.
and a cop pulled up to the four-way and
uh
busted us they all told on me and i went
to prison
and you went to prison for how long i
did uh
11 months so i tell people a year
because you know 11 months sounds a
little [ __ ]
oh you got to you got to flex a little
bit you got to stretch that out do you
still see those kids around that ratted
you out
the only thing i wanted to stretch out
what do you still see the kids that
ratted you around that ratted you out
no i did i did uh i did right when i
first got out
and um i confronted one of them and
he was like got all shaky and stuff and
then i just left it at that cause i was
like i'm a parole
i don't want those problems like yeah i
actually learned my lesson from it so i
was like [ __ ] that
so your your what's called a year in
prison
how how was your year man because some
people say yeah prison's not that bad
it it did it was a little scary because
my dad's a cop
and so like oh wow being in missouri i
was like i don't want nobody to know
yeah did you get one of those my dad's
not a cop tattoos on you
yeah dude i didn't have this [ __ ]
mustache during that i'll tell you that
now did you have to join a gang in there
no
no no no and then i mean no
it's missouri so i mean there's not
really a whole lot of gang [ __ ] going on
there's like white
gangs so like the peckerwoods and family
values and the prison gangs but
it's all prison politics it's prison
[ __ ] like none of it matters in the
real world
like a pub crawl yeah did you did you
make some good friends
no no not at all hell no
it was tight man i got through it and
but they're not people i want to hang
out with
you know it's a bunch of missouri cooks
and
you know that those type of people oh
yeah chefs
now tell me about this your father uh
what what was his reaction to it
he was like hey what the [ __ ] are you
doing with your life
and was he what kind of cop was he he
was a
dude my dad was the dare officer
dare to keep ben off of drugs dude um
i'll say this honestly bro go ahead go
ahead
i was just gonna say honestly like we
had a terrible relationship we kind of
we obviously saw different things
differently and then going to prison
brought us closer together because he
kind of sat back and realized like oh
[ __ ] my son
is actually going through some [ __ ] like
he needs help and
now me and my dad have a fantastic
relationship
does he support that nose piercing
that's beautiful man
no that's the one thing he does not
support yeah
no i dig it man no he is hating i'm not
hating i'm just
your dad's a cop you got your nose
pierced i'm sure your cops aren't down
that's half a handcuff dude that's all
that is man
dude i think uh yeah i think it's almost
yeah it's almost like a
like a unique story it's almost like the
blind side a little bit but like a white
dare officer son but yeah but he has a
dad we had this guy named
fat bobby that was the cop in our town
dude and
he was the dare cop and he would come
and people had to go help him get out
the car dude he was so big
people had to help him like just regular
people he'd pull up and have to get out
for a crime and criminals sometimes the
people committing the crime me help you
out we'd have to stop
and help him out of the vehicle yeah
yeah he was so
crazy bro that deer program never worked
for anybody and that mascot was that
lame ass dog hey here's their great idea
just say
no yeah that's all you got to do yeah
that's it but it's easier said than done
dudes dicks you know if you got the coke
you're getting a dick sucked but
just say no to drugs you know right man
yeah they didn't factor in everything
yeah you learned the hard way my man
yeah dude sometimes you got to carry the
one bruh
they should have told kids you'd get
your dick sucked if you don't have drugs
try something like that like
we'll suck your dick if you stay off the
drugs program yeah they're gonna change
the
marketing man yeah try to get a little
bit ahead without drugs challenge
yourself that's what it should have been
challenge yourself
yeah get a little bit ahead without the
drugs yeah yeah do it the right way like
a double entendre there
[Laughter]
you're trying that hooch in prison yeah
i tried man so i had this uh
i had a great jelly container i know
that sounds weird but like
it's like an easy squeeze great jelly
yeah that makes sense so i could make
sandwiches and [ __ ]
yeah flashlight bruh setting out too
long and it kind of fermented i opened
it and it smelled like wine
and i was like oh [ __ ] yeah i let it sit
for another month or two
and i drank that [ __ ] and it was
terrible and it didn't do anything for
me and it was just a it was a bad
experience oh wow
i smoked a little weed in there oh wow
how's prison weed
it's not good yeah that's cause someone
probably hit it in their butt to get in
the prison man 100
100 that's true and you just you're
thinking about it when you're rolling it
up and then
you're going outside and i had to mix it
with a little bit of tobacco because it
was such a small amount and then i
didn't even get high and i'm like
oh what the [ __ ] you doing this is what
got you here you're a terrible decision
maker
oh yeah you sound like mark norman right
there for some reason
no are you clean now or do you still
smoke the devil's dandruff
i smoke pot i'm actually about to go
bipod right now
[Laughter]
but i don't do anything else man i'm
completely clean off of all drugs and
[ __ ]
i got kids now shout out oh good for you
man good gang man
brother well look dude we didn't want to
give away any more money today but we
already feel like we have to so
we're going to send you 300 bucks to do
something fun with the kiddos
yeah man it's not much but it's
something just uh just a little just a
little uh
welcome back to regular life fun that's
what's up i appreciate it i'm about to
call the weed guy i told him to uh
i'll spend it on my kids that's all good
man get high with it bro
yeah yeah whatever you gotta do man
you know panicking my weed dealer was
calling me as i was connecting with you
guys and i was like
oh [ __ ] dude i'm gonna disconnect like
[ __ ] it
it almost didn't work out i got scared
oh well just don't sell the weed to your
kids man you'll be fine probably you
know
no dude no no and hopefully your dad's
not watching this show
hey yeah [ __ ] that guy hey uh
i got a quick question for you dude real
quick uh
uh uh yeah
yeah never mind never mind moments pass
you sure no what do you got man take
your time dude i thought i i had it
right there on the tip hold on let me
blow in this breathalyzer
uh oh yeah
yeah dude i ain't got it
oh yeah brendan stop telling people that
st louis sucks man i'm trying to see
some comedy bro
he did that [ __ ] too i didn't do that
i'm sorry man if you're on a podcast
you're like yeah
this place is great just stay the [ __ ]
away from saint louis
i almost had to fight a guy bro i was at
that show and i had a good time
all right brother i'll i'll come back
probably not to that clip
but i'll come back all right brother
love you all right all right be good
later brother that's awesome man wow i
need to blow in this car so he also has
a drinking problem as well and you're
sending this guy money
it might be just be probation nick said
we had to send him because he heard the
other
money he gave him 300 yeah but you
lowered it 300.
i had to lower to 300 dude i just felt
like the five might have been risky for
him
how the five he would he would have
bought cocaine he should get an amazon
gift card
not cash that's a small move that's
exactly what we'll do send my gift card
to target they get a bunch of kids toys
there yeah
yeah man yeah something where yeah just
keep maybe 300 and frozen yogurt
keep it out of his lungs man it's
another felon no
no we're no more felons today unless
there was one other guy who had a pretty
good story but he was the guy who kind
of he
couldn't join but maybe maybe at the end
maybe uh later in the year we'll do a
felons episode
uh this guy uh le two weeks ago with
christos stefano one guy had his ass
he said cowboy [ __ ] and he was
impregnating a cow oh that's right and
we were throwing out our theories how
that happens and this guy
gives us an explanation of how cows are
impregnated okay
david here from mystic hill farms what's
up david from alexandria i'm not live
man
i'm also a part of that nub club oh
double up them rabbit ears baby gang bro
hey theo since you neglected us they
were debating last week how to breed a
cow so i figured i'd give you a little
demonstration
oh first things first i'm the greatest
but these are semen tanks they've hurt
some of the grapes
we fill them with liquid nitrogen to
keep them cold so we can preserve
preserve them you pull up this can here
and there's your semen oh your canes
you pull one of them straws out but i
ain't gonna do it cause i ain't gonna
waste 50 dollars
you take one of them straws and you run
it over here
it's usually filled up with water at a
certain temperature you put it in there
boop
set your timer for a minute people say
45 seconds
but i do a minute i like it hot set you
up right here
injecting that cow down high this is
awesome you got your gun
here you pull the plunger back you get
your semen
you cut the tip off you put your semen
in there
you put your sleeve on oh yeah
and then you stick this in your shirt
because it's usually cold and fall when
we breathe
you let it warm up then you put your
glove on get your little pump of lube
and then you're ready to breathe you
pull this on out
you stick your arm up her ass brandon
okay and you're feeling around for that
cervix once you got the cervix
yep you slip this up in her vagina
oh yeah and then you feel for the front
of the
cervix once you get it in that's the
hardest part
of the car applebee's still another ring
it's either two or three rings i can't
remember
but once you're out you'll feel a little
give
and you're gonna shoot half to the right
horn
and then half to the left horn hey man
baby and then she's bread
wow anyways thank you for everything
y'all do
man y'all get me through the hay season
i love everything i listened to this
past weekend
um food diaries or
damn that's all right
damn food damn dude diaries bro that
dude is putting seed in
animals bro yeah yes man pregnant a lot
of cows that was a legit breakdown
wouldn't it
and all one shot that wasn't yeah really
effective that guy
wow uh are we sending him 500
he's gonna be fine i think he'll be fine
do you think
you could do ins insagnate a animal
right now
uh i'd love to milk a cow but as far as
getting uh
elbow deep in a cow's ass or vagina
probably a pass huh why you couldn't
handle it you think
it's just a lot it's messy isn't it i
don't know
i never know i don't know either i don't
know could you guys do it
hell no i think you'd do it it'd be
gross yeah
nick could definitely they could do it
yeah they could do it yeah nick seems
like a guy that does it
no judgment against it i've always
wanted to do fear factor i just feel
like
most those things are mental and yeah
i'll do it i'll stick my hand up there
you could about
you could guzzle like the donkey sperm
and stuff like that
that's like though that was the worst
one but i think i got him kicked off the
ear
kicked off the air oh i couldn't have
more than one sip no
yeah just a shot for me oh i don't even
know a shot bro
it'd have to be a shot i couldn't slurp
it like a slurpee i'd have to be stall
i'd have to not eat for two days and
then try it
that's fair if it was like real cold on
a hot summer day
hmm yeah i would need a strategy
yes to ingest it it can't be just a
lukewarm what about that kid what about
bone marrow you do it
meat bone whatever that is gh can you uh
take down some semen what would you
could you down some uh donkey semen
like a big cup of it donkey semen yeah
they did it on fear factor got them
kicked off the air
depends like am i gonna get like
absolutely shredded after or
let's find out yeah it'll be a quarter
horse by tuesday man you're going to be
great
um yeah we'll see we'll see you in the
preakness yeah we'll see man
but out in the lobby right now we've got
smokey joe
the guy who showed us some art
and see the art piece dude shout out to
alexandria louisiana shout out uh
northeast louisiana bro and everybody up
there doing it right and doing it wrong
man is that where this kid's from
northeast or northwest louisiana oh
what's up dog
boy you talented bat what's up you
talented little bastard
good to see you brother right here oh
yeah man
it's an honor to be here
yeah man that thing's great man oh thank
you
thank you yeah on the i thought it was
funny on the belt
i like did like oh you see like an image
of this whole thing
oh it's so good man that's swaggy bro i
can't believe that's what i look like
right there yeah it is and actually
that's really
good that's what i look like it looks
like kind of like uh looks good
joey is like tougher brother looking
yolked
dude that's awesome oh thank you wow
is that a picture from the comedy store
or that was
that's from now on i just got this on
uh i don't know what where the picture
was from but i just got it online i
looked up a picture of both of you guys
and that's great
i'm pretty sure that was just after a
fighter in the kid that's cool
i think it was from that belt from
fighting the kids yeah
that looks sweet dude you got a real
talent um
i kind of spread it out so i had this um
thing live painting at the w hotel and
in uh hey joe could we have you talking
in the
the mic yeah yeah yeah can we set that
up maybe on there so we can see it like
that or what's the best way so we can
get it in one of the shots or something
this couch it's nice huh
it's nick's just got that in here
actually that's a new sofa or something
nope take a little snoozer on this thing
meat hoof is fine you drove in from
where dude from phoenix
phoenix yeah i drove in we just kind of
made a little trip out of it
oh sweet man who's we you and your girl
me and my girl oh really you got a
little you gotta
oh we got a lady in here mama oh lonely
what's up girl
her name is dave he's doing it let's put
it in that corner maybe nick that's cool
yeah and then we can just edit in shots
of it yeah if you just put it in an
angle in that corner over there that
thing's great man yeah
i got to keep staying used to talking in
this thing
gang bro that thing's so good man looks
good in that corner too huh i'm gonna
have to leave it there yeah
that does look nice actually man dude
thank you so much man
yeah real talent my man how's how's it
been how's the art life been going
during covid
man during covet it's stayed you know
um i've tried to stay stay busy at i
work like a desk job too
what kind of desk job i work enrollment
for this university
oh interesting yeah from grand canyon
university oh grand canyon grand canyon
university i've seen the advertisements
for grant king university
advertisement for a real university too
it
you know they they like to say it is
yeah i think yeah
real university do they have a cafeteria
or not
on campus they have actually a lot of
food they got like that's a real
university chick-fil-a on campus got
which was that was taking a lot of my
dining dollars that would sell me
i love that i would kick i got java
juice a bunch of different things
wow oh yeah so they're doing pretty good
yeah they're living life
that's considered an education to
brendan yeah
once i saw that like the school had it
i'm like i'm sold i'm applied there how
long have you worked there
um so i went to school there got my
bachelor's and then i started working
there about
three years ago um doing enrollment it's
a lot of like
it's basically over the phone yeah the
whole day everybody they make the
tournament grand canyon university
i feel like they're they're about yeah
they were yeah they were in the whack
yep they lo
yeah they went really far this year they
had gone far like a few years back they
had kind of like some rebuilding years
but yeah this year they went yeah is
that where you met your lady at grand
canyon university she's
she's actually a phoenix local oh i
picked her up around there
okay and how long have you guys been
together okay
no no how long have you guys been
together two years oh two weeks
well this is new news oh respect two
weeks mrs newness
had to bring a girl here you know yeah
yeah
we're usually just a lot of dudes yeah
yeah who what weirdo would show if you
were just a dude you know
yeah no it was actually a funny story
because she um
she was running like an art event in
downtown phoenix and so she messaged me
and was like hey
i can get you a free booth downtown
putting your heart up so she kind of
like
slid that in here and then i hit her up
i'm like hey we should we should go out
and yeah that's been it's been two years
oh wow
yeah i love it that's a sweet deal
though and you guys are um
what uh okay
you guys drove down here from phoenix
yeah they did brendan yeah
because you don't want to fly because
the artwork would have got [ __ ] up the
artwork yep and it's
it's expensive to ship that stuff it is
man um and yeah getting it on the plane
now what kind of art is it is it acrylic
or is it
on matte finish what is it or is it out
like
indoor outdoor what do you think
no it's uh it's basically like aerosol
like spray paint
and then acrylic so most of it most of
what i do is acrylic
that's kind of like my my favorite
medium you know what you were talking
about yeah i know a little i know i have
some a little bit art at home yeah you
know the arts
yeah nothing's sweet man thanks
and phoenix is popping i've been i've
been torn in phoenix non-stop
i saw you in phoenix yeah man saw you
chappelle um brian i want to see theo
i've been i've been trying to yeah you
guys the show was sick man
i'll come out there man [ __ ] during
coven i haven't done a lot of touring
but
i'll tell you this actually it's a great
time to say i'm going to north carolina
and minnesota and baltimore and buffalo
and some other places
doing those it'll be on monday uh
announcing dates
later in the year yeah it'll be starting
in august i think good for you man
so looking forward to that right here in
the road the rat king's got to hit the
road baby i got a freaking uh
house payment now daddy get out there
and squeeze the cheese baby now what
about this do you want
how much art do you do like on a weekly
or monthly basis do you have like
ambitions to do art full-time like what
is it what is your
what is art in your life yeah so
basically with this desk job like i just
realized like i'm not
good at that like corporate like sitting
in offices and like having to act you
know
an artist man that's not me you know so
i'm like i gotta figure out
something that's you know i can run for
myself so yeah i basically just
started painting like every single night
i was in a small apartment i will
i started on campus but moved to a small
apartment and just started just packing
the thing full of paintings like i
couldn't even
walk through my hallway just rent in a
room and basically yeah i mean i just do
it
probably every night just trying to like
make make something i noticed it was
something i was like sort of
good at you know at least i was like not
bad at it yeah so i'm like i'm sure
i'm just gonna like run and then what's
your ig because i'm sure that's how
people are commissioned
painters for me yeah it's uh smokey joe
paint co yeah smokey joe pink
do you use what type of uh drug medium
do you use to help you paint if anything
get that kratom flowing man
do you a little bit yeah yeah i try not
to do too much drugs though
yeah you know a little have to do some
people do drugs and paint
yeah yeah when i was younger like your
construction
or whatever that is you know i'm talking
about we had some guys that were paint
dude i remember actually doing drugs and
painting now that i think about it
so one time we got hired to paint this
lady's house when i was in high school
so we painted it dude but then she had
to come see it and the paint was all
[ __ ] up
so we undid all the light bulbs in all
the rooms the day
[Laughter]
so it just looked pretty good yeah
that's most of my paintings just dim the
lights
actually but so you just dim the lights
if you dim the lights then people don't
have to look at it you know they can't
tell if it's good or not
yeah the paint fumes with the aerosol
that stuff will get you going ooh i love
it
i dude i love to sniff paint myself oh i
had a tough afternoon here one day with
one of those uh huffer cam with one of
the things to clean off the
compressed air yeah don't put me around
a keyboard cleaner dog
asdf jkl sim bro i'm [ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] going pretty deep man i
moved shift button
this guy's got a debate club for us
maybe joe can uh interject with us as
well
okay great welcome my man this guy's
obviously been sniffing glue
yo what up theo what up brendan got a
debate club for you
when you guys come out to my home state
florida what are you guys more down to
do
that universal studios
harry potter
[Music]
or that disney world
yep there's a dog in my head
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let me know what you guys think gang
gang buzz buzz
chin your bobby lee costume sucks suck
let's go there you go chin it depends if
you got
universal is better if you don't have
kids
but something at disneyland a lot of it
there's a lot of gay men that get
rejected from jobs there and go on to
work
at like a lot of secondary type of
um yeah maybe bush guard busch gardens i
think is a little bit more even keel
disney world is like a gay destination
for like
i don't think i feel like busch gardens
takes all the gay guys you ever you have
seen charlie brown in the suit i'm like
damn my charlie brown has so much sugar
really yeah i haven't seen that
but a lot of those men end up sniffing
his ass
working at starbucks if they don't get
hired at disneyland i notice that
um starbucks or librarian you see a lot
of
young men librarian that are didn't make
it at disney i don't want to say it like
that but didn't make it at disney
there should be a documentary about the
guys who don't make it at disney cause
it's like a
it's like a gay mecca yeah it is to get
that job and if you don't get that it's
almost like
it's like the ivy league for
homosexuality it's a big deal but
there's been some famous people have
played some of those disneyland
characters
yeah haven't had the top job there
playing one of those characters
yeah dude what would most people apply
for getting in that suit i think getting
that suit oh yeah yeah they're sweating
their ass off
taking pictures all day it's a hotbed
it's a beautiful feel it seems like
yeah i keep it real my kid i'm like that
ain't [ __ ] that ain't buzz lightyear
my man
yeah yeah that's that's the guys who
made a lot of bad decisions
yeah so i say universal studios man
that's what i say
and they got universal studios during
halloween is lit as
[ __ ] the horror nights dude oh it's fun
i've always wanted to go to that
you all need to go somewhere man take
care let me see what celebs robin
williams
work there wow i'm pretty sure steve
martin did too
keep going well boom baby great book
born standing up wow when it first
opened he worked there
kevin costner was in the jungle cruise
i take it back michelle pfeiffer
i give it back richard carpenter not
familiar okay keep going
wayne brady makes sense he gets on my
nerves
kevin richards kevin richardson who was
the freaking backstreet boy
from lexington oh wow he just can't i
just
talked about last episode zoom em in
yeah huh i'll get them in
yeah man is that it that's that's it
kevin wow
that's a lot i'm telling you a lot and
then also adam ray
and there's a lot of gay violence there
yeah they fight over the suit
i would assume that yeah a lot of it man
it's weird because with covert they they
said no characters
oh really but they're in soups they're
in the biggest mask
to your point yeah and gloves and
everything dude they're the safest ones
it's all it's unbelie it's once you tell
so many lies there's just no way to even
corner it all up anymore you're right
did you guys see that giant disney fight
it was like last year right before the
pandemic uh yeah
at disneyland yeah and there's like a
bunch of cast members
it was it makes sense so it's hot sticky
it was all one
family uh
i was watching it trying to figure out
like who which family was
like who was in the wrong yeah oh wait
are those
is that a man and a woman yeah yeah this
busta rhymes character goes after
every woman but now you said busta
rhymes getting pink
yeah okay
oh damn in front of the kids the kids
crying of course man these people don't
care
damn look at the kids crying man that's
terrible oh
[ __ ] that's good
this takes a bunch of twists and turns
you don't see it coming oh look at the
girl in the vlog oh somebody can't do in
a cart
go ahead and push that doesn't need the
cart look at that oh she doesn't oh she
she needs it yeah she's wobbling around
look at the kid wandering around crying
god dawg
dark arts man and look at that
damn why is he punching girls i'm
telling you why
they get man is a gay man and that's gay
violence dog i'm telling you about this
is that busta rhymes man where the [ __ ]
make you when you need him dude
and look finally he's like i'm getting
my kid up oh he's got that double up
no you probably got that fast pass you
can play where's waldo with security
members just like height man
oh she just fell yeah she needed that
the wheels
oh come on look at the security look at
the fred flintstone in the back
pretending to be on a bluetooth adam
ryder
damn boys welcome to popeye's brother
[ __ ] is
[Applause]
oh no he's slapping like a gay dude why
does he do that
man dude how does no other grown man
step in and beat the [ __ ] out of that
dude
look at that oh they can't just hit
somebody look at the kid go back
10 seconds well that's his mom look at
the kid no back
look at that it's already learning
that's how you learn it right there
unbelievable look at this how does
nobody step in
dude yeah everybody's just filming i
mean what are you gonna do and what are
they fighting everybody keeps stepping
in
it's the happiest place on earth but
it's not though that's a lot now let's
finish it off strong
go to the parade where the lady has the
people dancing in the street
damn there's more nick they fight oh
yeah it takes a twist
there's one guy that actually stands
there he kind of steps in
disney what we were doing let's go to uh
parade watcher
um what is the uh dora explorer
what's going on here this is the best
door explore ain't disney dog
no no not float
right there parade parade's in the hood
oh that's
scottsdale oh that's my turn
all right oh this door this door is lit
[Music]
oh [ __ ] even the minions are lit
i know
[Applause]
more happy party i'd rather be part of
this this is what i'm talking about
that's what we need yeah that's the new
disney man
we need more of that less of that yeah
all right we got one what is this uh
yeah we'll close it out with a kinder
stinger and this is a man right here
hey yo king in the sting what up brendan
what up theo what up culture corner
shout out nick and chin love the content
love you guys
channel makes me laugh so much i'm gonna
make this short and sweet
king it or sting it what you guys think
about uh
that wall hanging hitter put a urinal in
your bathroom i just remodeled this
whole thing
had to put the urinal in i got a toilet
too
it's got plenty of that tp with that
wall hanging hitter
are you rich for the number ones what do
you think
gang gang buzz buzz dang gang man i love
that i've never seen that in a human
home
in kindergarten sam bazel's family had
one it was awesome all right don't brag
don't brag wow and so what is it it's a
oh just a urinal you can go use it
yeah like it like like a restroom urinal
dude what a
upgrade i've never seen that pretty nice
but i'm not able to just go out in my
living room and just order applebee's or
something like that's the only thing i
i wonder if i'll just like get
disillusioned where i am you know
growing up my uncle was rich and he had
a bidet and i used to think it was a
water fountain
oh
and you drink out of it so that's how we
got here
not shocked buddy yeah really shocked by
that
my older brother used to tell me as a
water fountain really yup
would it spray far like it would spray
all up in my face
ah yes that's got that
we had this guy bus named roy boy was
his name and he was i'm not gonna say
homosexual but he was
a little sugar in his tank he was mostly
he had a
maybe had a little bit of tank in his
sugar yeah that makes sense more tank
than sugar
and he used to make us pool water on our
backs like as kids and he would drink it
out of our back like a bicycle
oh yeah he's definitely a gay man now my
question is why would you guys a
military dude and he was like 11.
and he lied to us he said this is like
navy seal training he made us play navy
in his bathtub they had like a little
bit bigger bathtub for some reason
and he would make us play navy in there
and make the water get all crazy and you
guys are all naked
huh you guys are naked i don't remember
i was a child damn you still slurp that
bathwater off your back he did i know i
didn't drink any
i couldn't drink it he was on my own
back yeah but you'd sit still while you
slurped the water through the crack of
your back
i mean it tickled i'd quit pretty quick
yeah we use the straw
huh no dude
you bring a straw to party that's too
much
this ain't disney world okay put on that
old-fashioned slurp down the course
go doors
[Laughter]
okay minnie uh what else we got nick
uh do we wanna do one more let's do one
more just one more man
what do you think though what you got to
say on that uh uh once you chime in on
this one man you lead the charge it's a
disney party
all right bummed me out man ceo what's
up brandon
i've got a king of stinger for you this
is andre arlovski
zealand paternity leave in sweden we've
got
some 400 something days that we'll get
to 80 of our paycheck
oh yeah so we can stay on with the kids
so
staying home with this little fella oh
that's great man
cute kid or going to work
and missing out a lot of his first steps
and
things like that yeah that's a miracle
what do you guys think can you sing it
fraternity
gang gang buzz buzz
oh so cute man they get like 200
something days maternity leave between
the mom and the dad
480 and and they can split it between
them however they want
that's how it should be though so they
can enjoy the kid man america you gotta
dress right back to work
i would keep having children yeah i'd
just take years
two kids a year yeah yeah and just get
you get 80
of your pay but also in america they got
a lot of people that ain't working and
just having children let's be honest
that's another
big thing that's happening over here but
i like your attitude of having a job
first and then choosing to have a child
which sounds like a much better pattern
it seems like a good papa too yeah and
you're making that chatter son
seems like he's engaged and also it's uh
yes the son looked just like the man too
i think
oh yeah the song i didn't know like i
knew girls get maternity leave but in
america do guys
no never even oh this is some swedish
[ __ ] man oh yeah
in corporate america though though yeah
man the guy in the weekend
in seattle that's some woke [ __ ] yeah
that's my home turf
is it it is yes oh yeah you can get it
oh really kirkland i was gonna laugh out
there that comedy club remember laughs
it was there
it was probably maybe when you in
downtown kirkland uh i
i uh i don't know i love the economy
yeah yeah and like seattle and stuff are
shut down
really yeah so i don't know brandon you
say shut down all the time and it's not
shut down no i'm telling you in seattle
it's bad like what was the main one the
bellco area um australia is open i do
want to say that
and new zealand's open dude i got a
million messages you said australia
no you can't fly you can't fly in there
they're not wide open
well they told me to i i a lot of people
said that they are open
um there's a lot stricter definitely
than in arizona where seattle
yeah i go back for coco i got covered in
phoenix did you oh really
pretty sure when i got it they're little
losers my green room was lit
and i was like we're all getting covered
yeah show enough week later
i like that man i'm glad i got it yeah
you got it you got to do something man
build that immunity
and look at this child right here who
knows anything could happen with that
child man
he could grow up to be anything he wants
a burglar president
well see it's swedish champion yep yes
sweden you can
yeah yeah well dude the art ridiculous
man you got a talent give me your handle
one more time
you yeah it's uh smokey joe panko at
smokey joe paint co
yeah that made the studio my man yeah
we'll hang that up man joe thanks so
much for bringing it too
oh congrats on your girl too man oh yeah
she's a dime
oh yeah man yeah she's a cutie we are
pretty lonely in here
[Laughter]
[Music]
i'm sorry my friends keep staring at you
girl
we're pretty sad yeah meat tone is in
here how you doing meat tone you all
right
what's going on with you nothing i'm
just just
working chilling okay right on and how's
the lady front you got a lady
uh there was a girl i was screwing
around with when i was back in rhode
island
island but not out here yet do me a
favor don't say screwing around
i'm sorry yeah no you're good she
wouldn't like to hear that
there's a girl i was screwing back in
long island but uh
but now you're in l.a dude different
market my man yeah yeah
you've had better luck here in l.a or
rhode island usually he just got here
dude
oh he did give him a chance um but still
honestly uh
honestly rhode island because everybody
like it's just so small everybody knows
everybody so like i know like all the
people like i
hang i take out and hang out with so
it's just you're also a rhode island
eight
i appreciate that you're la-4 i think he
means they know his brother's famous
so he gets he gets girls back in real
life um
that makes sense nah i mean uh
it's all girls that don't even know him
really i try and like straightforward
which are most girls i mean this is also
gianni
so it's rhode island and it's power yeah
yeah that's true
um but no god bless gianni and we wish
you were here man he's
i love that dude he's one of a kind man
well i appreciate you man
what happened to him i don't know what
happened to him oh yeah famous so he
can't really work for us anymore
he blew up yeah yeah can't forget your
roots though
no yeah you can apparently um
what else we got that's all that's all
we got man thanks for driving down dude
thanks for the artwork brother oh man i
appreciate you guys yeah honestly like
when you guys put this up on
on the show and everything like it's it
really helped me
love it and the art and stuff man i
actually just started some uh nfts too
so oh type moves yeah trying to make it
something so i don't have to be in
boring like business meetings get you
out of there you're gonna live off your
lady forever
uh yeah and also help you so much got a
big wallet
i got some uh the new on monday i think
our tuesday new uh the tour dates will
be up for
so you can check it out and i'll be in
lexington kentucky i think it's may 6
through the 8th
and then houston texas may 20th
something
houston improv get your tickets yeah
thank you guys gang gang that's it
[Music]
flow is contagious browser outrageous
thicker than girls that are instagram
famous damn
hungry like i'm fresh off keto seeing
red like andrew santino
every song i hit like the great bambino
burning ate the queso and the quesoritos
but
everything's gonna be fine hate on me i
do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude that
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times
they sliding into my dms a couple of you
tribal couldn't beat them
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want to smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible
brendan's son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick me up
[Music]
on a string
[Music]
you